great
then let's go ahead and get started um
welcome everyone to the
uh thursday um d mice informatics
research conference
and our normal time for this uh
installment
and as often happens at the end of the
academic term we have a number of
defenses proposal defenses and so forth
today we are having a
phd dissertation proposal defense
from nate evans who is known to
most if not all of the attendees at the
meeting
nate is a phd candidate in the
bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine major
he previously to ohsu studied biological
physics at the university of washington
and was employed as a mechanical
engineer developing lung cancer
diagnostics
his research goals are to develop robust
drug response models to aid decision
making
in precision oncology his current work
has broad translational application and
drug development
combination therapy prediction clinical
patient
response prediction and patient therapy
toxicity prediction
so he's defending his dissertation
proposal today
we'll get feedback from the audience we
we after his talk we'll open it up to um
everyone here then the um the public
will leave and
and leaving behind his uh um
dissertation committee
if they have any further questioning or
um
suggestions that that came from the
public talk for him
and if um he passes that part of the
um if he passes the proposal defense
then he moves on to do his dissertation
work and we will hear back from him
some number of months down the road
where he'll come to defend his
dissertation
so i'm going to turn it over to nate
thanks bill i appreciate that
introduction um
first of all can everyone see the the
right screen presentation mode and hear
me
yeah looks good to me perfect all right
so uh the title for today's proposal
defense
is improving prioritization of
pre-clinical drug screening based on
genetic background
by using bayesian optimization in a
continuous distributed representation
there we go so uh to frame the talk
today
i want to start with this uh this
research question where
if we're given a cancer omics how can we
identify
an optimal treatment and so there's a
number of ways to approach a question
like this
um however from a from a computational
perspective
we often start by asking what data do we
have available to us
and so there's been a ton of work done
in the molecular character
characterization of cancers and these
are stored in repositories like
the cancer genome atlas and the cancer
cell line encyclopedia
or the gene expression omnibus
and then we've also done work in
characterizing
oncology drugs this is commonly done by
their molecular structure
or by which proteins
the drug binds to and how it changes
protein
behavior and then kind of in parallel to
this
there's been pretty remarkable work done
in measuring the functional response of
different
cancer model systems and so these model
systems could be
cell lines or mouse models um and when i
say functional response a common data
type for this would be
like dose response curves or cell
viability
and so given this data we can think
about
building these predictive models that
take in
your cancer omics and drug features and
tries to predict
the functional response of of these
model systems
and it's really important to remember
that when we build these models
we need to make sure that our results
are going to generalize to patients
because that's where we get our impact
and this is going to kind of frame the
talk for today
and so um as oncology therapeutics
currently stand
um we have a major issue with
drug resistance and so there was this
paper
that cited in 2017 of about .6 million
cancer death 90 of those were attributed
to
drug resistance and this problem that we
see is
is especially common in uh in targeted
monotherapies where initially we have
very
we have pretty good response the the
tumor is sensitive
and responds well however over time
we see the the tumor acquire
resistance and stop responding to the
drug and we believe that one of the
reasons for this is this tumor
heterogeneity where
there's multiple clones uh cancer clones
some of which
may be sensitive to a drug and some may
be resistant
and so the drug essentially acts as this
selective pressure
that evolves resistance and so one of
the
ways to address this is by using
uh combinatorial therapeutics where we
use more than one drug
and you know this might target
more of the cancer clones or it could
also
um result in what we call synergistic
behavior where
the effect of the drugs together are
much better than either
single agent now we also see a problem
with
in adjuvant therapy where the side
effects can impact the quality of life
of patients
and so in extreme cases this can result
in discontinuation which can affect the
the overall outcome of our patients and
so
if we can improve the toxicity profiles
of these drugs then
i think we can also address that problem
and so our goal here is that we want to
get more and better
therapeutics into the hands of
clinicians where that they can
do some good for patient treatment
however there's this problem as well
in in the research pipeline specifically
in getting these oncology drugs through
fda trials
and so for monotherapies that enter
clinical trials very few of them
actually get fda approval
and as a quick overview there's there's
three primary phases of
an fda trial and the first one addresses
the toxicity of a drug and then the
second phase
looks at if the drug is effective at all
in treating the given disease
and then the final the phase three looks
at
comparing to the standard of care so is
it any better than what we already have
and um and so this
this 3.4 of monotherapies that actually
enter
are approved and so we have this real
bottleneck
in the research pipeline there and we
want to try to improve that in some way
and so we might just start by asking
why do we need to build computational
models to predict these drug
combinatorics at all
why don't we just measure everything at
the bench and pick the the drug
combinations that work the best
and the problem with this is that this
combinatorics problem becomes
intractable quite quite rapidly and then
on top of that there's two
additional axes to consider one that
genomic differences
can change how a tumor
responds to drug so the drug sensitivity
and then we can also prioritize
concentration specific combinations
and so this becomes a really large
search space and as an example
let's say that we want to explore pairs
so two drug combinations of 10 drugs and
we're going to measure 7 concentrations
which is
fairly common with the dose response
curve and we want to do this with a
thousand cell lines
and so in this example to to measure
every combination
it would require 2.2 million assays
now if we bump that up to a hundred
drugs that's going to be
242 million and if we bump that up to a
thousand drug that's 24 billion
and so we i think it's easy to recognize
that
we really can't measure everything and
so this is a bit of a shift
to how can we efficiently explore this
drug space
to identify those therapeutic
combinations without having to measure
all of them
now let's take a quick step back and
imagine that we've come up with this
computationally guided research
methodology that
takes in cancer omics or genetic
background
and produces an optimal therapeutic
which could then go on to
fda trials and the question is what
would success look like here
and so first for any inputs we want to
generate some output we don't want to
fail to identify a therapeutic for some
for some tumor we also want to
understand
why we prioritize the drugs that we do
so this comes down to the
interpretability of our methodology
and because a lot of the available data
comes from model systems we need to make
sure that whatever we prioritize
generalizes to patients that's where we
get our translational impact
and we want to minimize those toxicities
both for
getting drugs through phase one fda
trials
and for uh the problems with side
effects during adjuvant therapies
and then finally there's this these
pragmatic bounds in research where
if we want to have translational impact
we really have to make this fast cheap
and efficient
and so we want that
and for context this is going to be a
preclinical step
which would go into clinical trials
so there's been a lot of work in drug
response modeling
and then deep learning is a kind of a
subset of machine learning commonly used
for this
however there's still a number of
limitations the first one i'm
bringing up is what we call inflexible
modeling and i'm not sure that's quite
the right term but
it's this idea that we have difficulty
in
incorporating different data types or
different forms of data like prior
knowledge or structural information
and so addressing that can really be a
boon to the field
we also in drug response we often have
small data sets
and this comes to you know compared to
the massive search space we can't
measure everything
and so we have sparsity and this
translates to what we call epistemic
uncertainty where
we may just not have data to
characterize the underlying model
and then there's a second form of
uncertainty
when we have really noisy data types and
this is called alliatoric uncertainty
and we commonly see this with
genomic or ohmic measurements where we
can have significant noise
or with drug response
metrics like cell viability that has
significant
noise between replicates or between
between data sets that can have pretty
poor concordance
now with deep learning we commonly think
of these models as black box that have
inputs that come in and predict some
output and they're really powerful
however
they also often suffer in their
interpretability and so there's
a number of more recent methods for
addressing this specifically
in drug response but i think we can do
better as well and so
um this is a a goal of ours
and then finally there's this concept of
parameter sharing
where and to explain that it's easiest
done
with convolutional neural nets and
this method learns a what they call a
convolution or a kernel
which can be applied to a contiguous
region of pixels
to extract some feature
and what a method like this does is take
advantage of the structural information
in the image more specifically that
nearby pixels
are spatially similar and so in other
domains
when we can recognize this structural
information
we can also take advantage of parameter
sharing and that can be
uh wildly successful or advantageous
to model performance
now i touched on that we have
significant uncertainty
in in drug response
due to either we we don't have enough
data or the data that we do have is
noisy
and so to address a problem like that we
can use this
um a method called uncertainty
quantification
where we train a probabilistic function
to
explicitly recognize where we have
enough supporting evidence to make a
prediction
and and and we can do this with what we
call probabilistic predictions
and so to explain what those are let's
imagine that
in this figure at right we make a
prediction at x equals seven
and so the prediction of y is centered
around zero
however it's a probability distribution
over a range of values
and so for this example our probability
distribution is is very narrow
right around zero so we have high
confidence that the value of y
is close to zero however
if we make a prediction at x equals
negative seven we have a really
significant spread
on uh on the prediction of y and so
because of that we have very low
confidence
it could be negative five it could be
five we really can't say
and so methods like this are really
advantageous when
we want to use our predictions for
decision making or
if we want to reduce the false positives
and i really like this concept that
we're letting the model say i don't know
instead of
forcing it to make a prediction
and this becomes advantageous in later
now the methods i propose are going to
involve what's called a variational
autoencoder so to explain what that is i
want to start with an autoencoder
and this is an unsupervised form of
neural networks
and what we do is we take some input
data in and we bottleneck
our neural network and then we use this
this reduced dimensional latent space in
the bottleneck
to try to reconstruct the original data
and so the last function just becomes
the error between the reconstructed and
the input data
and so this actually has a lot of
similarity to principal components
analysis
however pca is linear and so if we think
about
uh projecting our data onto one of these
linear
pca components we would project the the
blue dots onto the red line that would
be pca
however autoencoder learns this
non-linear
component and we would project the data
onto that and so i think it's pretty
straightforward to recognize that
in situations where we have complex
non-linear data the autoencoders can be
really really
advantageous
now variational autoencoders they have a
similar architecture but a different
task their goal is actually to model the
probability distribution of a data set
or of an observation
and so they do that by taking in some
input data like the auto encoder
and bottlenecking the the network down
to some reduced
dimensionality however rather than just
predicting a single value
for that latent space it predicts both a
mean value
and a variance value and now we can make
the assumption that our data is normal
in the latent uh in the latent space and
we can sample from a normal distribution
and so what we've done is inherently
characterize or represent our input data
in this probabilistic
way which is pretty cool and so to build
some intuition on
uh on how this method works let's
imagine that
we've trained a variational autoencoder
on the mnist data set
and mnist is images
of hand-drawn numbers and so if we train
this variational autoencoder
we can sample from the latent space and
so this
this new image below
is if we were to sample from some region
of the laden space
the the number is the image we would get
from the decoder
and so you can see that this this latent
space does a really nice job
of representing the images in two
dimensions
not just that but it's done a good job
of blending
one number to the next and quantifying
any ambiguity or uncertainty
so for instance uh down down here
where ones eights and seven all blend
there's a lot of ambiguity
as well as up here with the zeros and
sevens
now we can think of this in from the
other side
where if we take some input data in so
imagine
we feed that image of the two into our
network then we produce this
probabilistic representation in the
latent space so it's going to predict
some normal distribution down here in
the twos
and so that that's pretty neat however
um
let's imagine that our input data is
instead of just being a clear two let's
let's pretend that we
can't really tell what it is maybe it's
a two maybe it's a three well in that
case
our um our encoder function can predict
a value
overlapping both two and threes and so
we've we've now quantified our
uncertainty that
the input data could be a two it could
be a three we're not totally sure
and so that's kind of that
that uncertainty quantification that i
like so much
now these are really powerful methods
and
they work well in a number of tasks
especially low data volume tasks but
one of the reasons that i really like
them is this idea of learning
disentangled variables which we can
think of as
independent variables and so that's
shown in this
figure at right where this was taken
from a variational auto encoder
trained on images of celebrities faces
and what it learned is that if you
sample
from a higher value of that x
latent variable then you can add or
remove
glasses from the face whereas if you
sample from
the the second the y-axis latent
variable you can change the type
of glasses and so this is really cool
because they're independent variables
they're very interpretable
and um you know as you're adding glasses
you're not also changing hair color
um so this this really does add a lot of
functionality and interpretability
to our models
so here are my aims overview um
from a high level aim one is just to
build a drug response model
we're going to employ a variational
autoencoder and there's
a little bit of nuance in how we set up
our encoder architecture that'll operate
on graph ontologies
and then we'll train this model on uh
cell line data where we use
unperturbed features to predict
both perturbed expression features and
those those classical metrics of drug
response like cell viability
and then in aim two we're going to shift
away from just
trying to predict an optimal therapeutic
and we're going to make this assumption
that
we probably don't have enough data to
to have high confidence in any of these
combinatorial predictions
however we can explore efficiently
and so we're going to think about
reframing this drug combination
prediction as an optimization problem
and we'll go in more depth on how we do
that
so this is the official um
specific games one uh and the the key
points to take out
from here is that we're going to train
this variational auto encoder to predict
drug response and perturbox from
unpredictable mix
now before i get into the details here i
want to introduce this
this prior art and it's a model called
dr vae
and they have a really nice graphic
framing the problem this is actually a
very similar task
and and architecture to the aim that
i've proposed however it has number
limitations
first of all they use fully connected
networks
for their encoder and decoders and so
this doesn't take advantage
of of any structural or prior knowledge
it doesn't use parameter sharing and i
think that's a bit of um
a limitation they also only trained it
on
the linx l1000 data set which is
expression rna expression features
and so i think we can do better on a
number of other data sets
and so we'll we'll benchmark against
this model to see if we're
improving
this is the architecture of my proposed
model
and uh the main thing to note here
is that i'm proposing that we use two
generative or probabilistic layers
so z1 and z2 will both be probabilistic
where z1 represents cell state
and z2 will represent the functional
response
or perhaps the cell viability and the
reason i think this is really important
is that you could imagine if we have
absolute certainty
in cell state in z1 we could still have
very significant uncertainty
in the functional response of that cell
state
and by so and so by separating these two
i think we're really going to improve
the calibration of our of our
predictions
now each one of these encoder or decoder
functions
are just parameterized by neural
networks
and when i refer to them throughout the
talk i'll call them the cell state
encoder or the perturbation decoder or
the functional
decoders and for the next couple
slides i'm going to walk through a toy
example
uh showing how i'm i want to set up my
encoder architecture because there's
some nuance there
and so first uh this encoder
architecture is going to operate
on some graph ontology specifically
protein protein interaction graphs where
nodes represent proteins and the edges
represent
protein interactions and so the first
thing we can do
is overlay our ohmic features as node
attributes
however one thing to note is that we
often in these ohmic data sets we have
sparsity in which features are actually
measured
and so because of that we'll have to
address it and we can do that with
imputing
and there's some really nice methods
that have already been developed
specific to imputation on graphs
and so we that fits very nicely into
this
and then the next step well first let's
recognize that this base
graph that i've produced
it essentially represents a cell line's
interactum which proteins are
interacting with each other
however we know that from cell line to
cell line
there's pretty significant differences
in the interactome
that these maybe in one cell line two
proteins do
interact and then another they don't and
so to address this variability
i'm proposing we use i use what's called
an attention mechanism
to predict individual observation
interactomes
and so this shifts our
undirected unweighted network into a
directed weighted network
and this is also really nice because to
some extent we're borrowing an idea from
pharmacology
specifically called coupling where in a
signal transduction network
we can think of the signal or the
information either
growing or decaying due to
the number of inputs in the outputs or
how
two proteins might interact and so in
this
uh in this methodology i'm interpreting
these edge weights
as what i call coupling coefficients
because they're they're
kind of implicitly bottlenecking the
information that can pass
between two genes and by doing this
we can introduce a really novel way of
encoding our drug perturbation and so if
some drug targets a given protein
we can think about modifying the edges
to or from that protein
to encode the actual perturbation
and so notice that those edges have
decreased so maybe if that drug was an
inhibitor that would be a good encoding
now the last step is to ask how we
actually
learn from from this data how do we
actually recognize the complex patterns
that we can make predictions from
and to do that we're going to use
something called graph convolutions and
to walk through a toy example
of how a graph convolution works we'll
just look at one node
so the next layer node value here
is going to be a the sum of all of its
neighbors including its self-edge weight
which is that one
and then we have the edge weight of
incoming edges
times some function of the neighboring
node values
and we put that in a non-linearity and
that becomes the next
node layer notice that in this case
i'm only i only care about edges coming
into my node that's a hyper parameter
that we might choose
and so really what this is doing is
allowing uh information to pass from
node to node and we can extract more
complex features
but it does it in a way that constrains
the features interactions
so only uh only edges
that exist so when edges exist
we allow those features to interact
and that comes down to prior knowledge
and so that toy model that i just walked
through can be summed up
in this image and i'm not going to spend
a whole lot of time here except to say
that we can
represent this a little more cleanly
and we can revisit if there are more
questions
so to revisit this idea of
encoding our drug perturbation as edge
modifiers
let's focus in on kinase inhibitors and
so
the signal through a kinase inhibitor is
mediated by its
upstream proteins and the binding of a
phosphate
which is going to stabilize the active
conformation
and produce some downstream signaling
and so we can model that
by this coupling coefficient which i'm
interpreting as those edge weights in my
previous model
now in the presence of a kinase
inhibitor that drug binds to the kinase
it stabilizes the inactive conformation
and we reduce the signal out
and so the question now becomes how do
we change
that coupling coefficient as a function
of drug features
now this is really nice because it's
mechanistic and interpretable however
there are some limitations
in that we have to know uh which targets
a drug binds to and we have to know how
tightly the the drug binds to
to the target we also need to know that
how the drug changes protein behavior so
when it binds does it activate the
protein or does it
inhibit the protein and that's very
important as well
and then finally because we're encoding
this as
as an edge modification we we need to
know
gene gene interaction knowledge and that
needs to be accurate
so i've done some preliminary work here
and starting with the definition of
binding affinity this equation here
where k d is binding affinity
we can derive this function where c star
represents the drug perturbed coupling
coefficient
and this is in terms of the drug
concentration
and the drug binding affinity to some
specific
to some specific drug target
so moving on to what data types can we
use to train a model like this
i want to revisit basically the the
elements or the or the
paths of information through the model
and so
we can create these unperturbed
cell state representations that would be
the blue
the blue circles there or we can create
a perturbed cell state representation
using our
drug perturbation method and then using
these latent representations
we can predict cell viability or
we can predict the expression
of those cell states so
now the routes of data or of information
through this model
dictate what data types we can train the
model with
and so first we can think about the
unsupervised approach where
we used where we use unperturbed omics
to predict unperturbed expression
this is probably the most classical form
of vae training
we also by definition know that an
unperturbed cell line should have cell
viability of one so we can annotate that
and then we can also use this drug
perturbation encoding to create a
perturbed cell state
and then we can predict uh perturbed
expression features
so this lets us take advantage of data
sets like the lynx l1000 which measures
perturbed expression
or the cancer perturbed proteomics atlas
which measures perturbed proteins and
then last um
we have this classical form of drug
response training where we we predict
cell state
and uh and and then we use that to
predict
cell viability or or drug response
metrics
and so this is really nice because these
four different forms or routes represent
different data types
that we can use to train the model and
this addresses that low data volume that
we often see in drug response
now i'm not gonna spend a whole lot of
time on this
table uh the key pieces are that i've
identified
a number of different data sets um
with fallback options to use in training
this model and and i think there's
a lot of work to be done in into
choosing and optimizing these how we can
incorporate them
so to evaluate a model like this
we can use hold holdout test sets
to evaluate different metrics of
performance however i've broken this
down
into a number of really critical
questions that i think we need answered
the first one being are our predictions
well
you remember back to my symposium
calibration is this metric
of uncertainty quantification
performance and so for that we can use a
metric like
expected calibration error but the
reason
i i care about this is that because in
aim 2
this the prediction calibration becomes
very important
now for the second question we want to
make sure that
our latent representing representation
is uh
is good at characterizing the cell state
and so we can evaluate that with uh how
accurately can we predict perturbed
expression
and for this we can actually benchmark
against dr vae
as it has a very similar architecture
and task
we also want to make sure that we can
predict drug response well
um once again we can benchmark against
dr vae however there's two additional
models that i would consider
one called drug cell from the idiker lab
and another one called
deep cdr that has pretty admirable
performance right now
last or these last two we want to make
sure that we can interpret
our predictions and the idaker lab has
done some really incredible work on
how you might do this in deep learning
and so we can co-opt a few of those
ideas
and then last because we're going to use
this continuous latent representation
of our model in aim2 we want to make
sure that this is smooth and informative
and there's some qualitative methods we
can use to try to address that
so moving on to aim2 we're going to
shift from
um instead of just trying to predict an
optimal therapeutic
let's make the assumption we don't have
enough data to do that
and instead let's ask how do we most
efficiently explore
this massive drug space
and so we're going to do this by using
the latent representation of cell state
from our aim 1 model
or alternatively we can use dr vae if it
outperforms
and um and we're going to
let the model request data where it'll
be most
informative or most useful and we
believe that this will converge
to an optimal therapeutic after some
chain of prioritizations
and so i want to introduce this prior
art
which has a very similar task in a
different domain
the goal of this model was to optimize
chemical
design and so what they did is they
trained a variational auto encoder to
um uh which took smiles or
molecular structure as input and and
created this continuous molecular
representation
but the smiles is just a string
representation of uh
of drug structure or of uh chemical
structure
and so once they've created this
continuous representation
they were able to train classifiers to
predict some property
that they might want to optimize over
and so they've shown that in the graphic
at right where the global maximum here
represents an optimal property
and so if they find that that global
maximum
and then locate the corresponding latent
space
and they can decode that back into the
smiles representation back into a
testable drug structure
and so this is a really nice way of
taking a very
high dimensional difficult problem
creating a low dimensional
representation of it
and then optimizing in that low
dimensional representation
and we're going to try to do the same
task however
in uh in drug combination prediction
and so uh to understand this we have to
first kind of go over this idea of
bayesian optimization
which is the method we'll use to
actually explore
and this is this is a method commonly
used in hyper parameter optimization
where you can imagine for
if you're trying to build a random
forest with
the highest accuracy you have to choose
the hyper parameter the number of trees
in that random forest and depending on
what you choose can
change the accuracy of your model after
you've trained it
and let's imagine that this is a really
big model and it takes
it takes a day to train well in this
case we can't
actually measure all possible
k values and so uh to do this really
efficiently
we can train a probabilistic we call
this a surrogate function
to predict the model performance from
the number of trees in the random forest
and that's represented with that purple
and blue line in the figure
the black line represents the true
model performance and so using this
probabilistic function
we can
we can generate what we call an
acquisition function and that's this
expected improvement here
a really intuitive example of an
acquisition function would just be
the upper confidence bound and so
using the acquisition function guides
you where
like which k values we should next test
um to most efficiently explore this
space
and so it's this it's really nice um
really clever method of of
optimizing hyper parameter optimization
or essentially any
black box blacks black box optimization
and so we're going to use the same
method however we want to use it for
drug combination exploration
so the x-axis is going to be the latent
representation
of that we would take from our aim1
model
and the y-axis is this metric of drug
response
and in this figure we could imagine that
it's one minus cell viability
so we're trying to look for a global
maximum here which represents an optimal
therapeutic
now if we were just to use the upper
competence bound
as our acquisition function we would
identify this
this red line identifying that
that's where we should uh the model
should ask
for more data and so using this latent
representation we can decode it back
into a set of drug combinations which we
can test at the bench
now i've shown this figure before but
for the sake of simplicity let's
for the moment forget about uncertainty
and just represent that
our encoder function can create some
point in the latent space that
represents
a uh the cell state representation
also with some drug we can create a
perturbed
cell state representation and you can
imagine that for
any unperturbed cell we can create many
many different perturbed
cell states however not all perturbed
cell states
and this could be done with different
drugs
or a combination of drugs or maybe
a different concentration of the same
drug now if we imagine
all possible perturbations that could
have happened on a cell line
and all the resulting cell states that
would come from that
then we get this subspace that
represents the perturbable
states of a given cell line and so by
calculating this
what we've done is condition on a set of
ohmic features representing a cell line
that becomes the first step in our
algorithm for aim2
the second step is to use our bayesian
optimization methods that we went over
to identify this candidate region
representing that
it's an optimal region to explore
in terms of this therapeutic metric that
we want to optimize
and then the last step is to take the
candidate region
and decode that back and do testable
drug combinations
now
now everything that i've proposed up to
this point
has used cell viability as the metric
that we're trying to optimize and the
problem
is that cell viability is essentially
cytotoxicity
and uh and there's nothing keeping our
algorithm
from prioritizing very high
concentrations of a drug
or multiple drugs in combination that
essentially would just kill
all cell lines and the problem with that
is that
it's essentially it would be a very
toxic
treatment to any patient and we would
never use it
and so we can address this by imposing
some constraints
uh the first and most naive constraint
would be to control the sum of drug
concentrations
alternatively we could calculate the
average cytotoxic response
of some given candidate region over
either a set of control cell lines
or potentially all cell lines
and then the third one is if we go back
to this idea that
we have these subspaces that represent
the perturbable region of a cell line
then we can imagine two subspaces
one substrate subspace that represents
the turbo region of the cell line that
we're trying to prioritize
for and then another subspace which
represents the
perturbable region of all other cell
lines
and if those two subspaces don't overlap
or don't entirely overlap then we can
infer a selective response
not necessarily a cytotoxic a selective
cytotoxic response but at least a
cell state differences
and then finally the fourth one is this
idea of
prior knowledge that if we know
combinations that are toxic we could
actually use the
latent space to train tox trained
classifiers to predict the toxicity
and there's already been some really
really nice work done
on incorporating such classifiers into
uh into bayesian optimization as
constraints and so that's actually a
really exciting
avenue however it could be challenging
to
to build these toxicity data sets
especially in cell lines
now a validation of the of an algorithm
like this can be
a little challenging however there's
both a computational route
and and kind of a wet lab route
so for the first question do does our
algorithm prioritize effective
candidates
the computational method for this would
be to withhold
uh known effective observations
and then look at their rank in our
prioritization and what we would expect
to see is that they're
ranked fairly high you know that we
should explore the
these regions alternatively
we could also do bench testing of
the prioritized candidates and we would
want to do this for both positive and
negative to make sure that we
were doing this well
also because the way bayesian
optimization is set up
we we don't necessarily assume that
every prediction or every prioritization
is going to be a super effective
candidate remember we're trying to
converge
to that global maximum and so really we
need to test this chain
of prior prioritizations and so we could
do that with bench testing if we
um iteratively test multiple um
drug combinations however we could also
do this with a simulation where we make
up fake data
and we withhold the majority of it from
the data and then let it iteratively
request data
as it makes the predictions and what
we'd expect to see is convergence
to the global maximum and then the last
last validation step would be to make
sure that we
prioritize low toxicity combinations and
so we can look
for selective cytotoxic selective
cytotoxicity
in the cell lines of interest compared
to control cell lines
or we could potentially look at how well
the combinations are
are handled in mouse models
now to circle back to impact of research
like this
i think that if it's well done this
could really change how we approach
oncology um drug screening
and there's a number of ways that's
going to affect you know patient
impact or translational impact the first
of which
if we can make this a efficient and
rapid method
and identify these combinations we can
just put more drugs
into the pipeline which is obviously
um a benefit
if we can improve this the toxicity
profiles
of these drugs that you know via our
toxicity constraints that i touched on
and i think we can also bump up the
number of drugs that make it through
phase
one if our convergence algorithm
identifies more optimal therapeutics
then that's also going to bump up the
numbers
for phase two and phase three which
ultimately puts more drugs
into the hands of clinicians where they
can help patients
and so i think that's pretty exciting
and
if done well could could have a lot of
impact
and with that i'd like to acknowledge my
advisor and dak
and everyone who helped me prepare for
this talk and put the ideas together
and i'll take questions
great thanks thanks for a nice talk
people who have questions can either
unmute and speak up
or type into the chat
nate this is shannon great job um you
know one of the things that
just kind of going to your last slide um
we think about is you know how soon is
now are we ready
you know for this so if this is if your
gestation is successful what do you
think some of the next steps would be
we're thinking about actually having
something that really could be put into
a pipeline
yeah um you know i think this
uh would work well integrated into um
like a a bench uh like a pre-clinical
screening uh lab
where this would guide um exploration
um
it's a good question um and i'm not
totally i don't have a
great answer for you um
your answer was fine you're right it's
just a thought it's something for you to
think about you know we talk a lot about
the methodology development but if we
actually want to have clinical impact or
translational impact it's always good to
kind of look to the horizons too
in terms of thinking about and you've
thought a lot about this with the
optimization piece and the
efficacy so you're already thinking
about these metrics but just something
to keep in mind
right you know what is the kind of chasm
between here and implementation
right
so nate can this is shibo can you go
back to where you introduced the vie
this one right uh okay next slide how
you are going to use
this okay keep going
keep going there's one slide
where you wanted your
latent variable 1 corresponds to
one versus two corresponds to different
maybe 15 page 15.
oh the bayesian optimization slide no no
no
before that okay
okay maybe uh let's see 11 on top
what about 15.
okay so here page 15. z1 z2
so you said um you have two latent
variables with z1 and z2
and um hopefully the one corresponds to
the cell c representation and z2 would
be the functional response
representation
um my question is that how can you
control
what latent variable corresponds to what
you know this is not this is to be
discovered from the data
you can't really dictate how many z's
are there
well you could somewhat discrete how
many these are but you can't tell
or dictate which z corresponds to what
you know the the
the mnist data for instance and then the
the face image with hairstyle and
sunglasses um those happen to be
the latent variables that was discovered
from the data
you can't really go i don't think i'm
not sure what mechanism would be to
to go tell can you find a variable that
corresponds to
if somebody's wearing a sunglass uh
you know this is my point um right so
interpretation of latent variables art
would kind of be done uh after we've
trained the model that we'd have to go
in and evaluate each one
um so so one one way that we can
separate z1 and z2 though or is
at least how i'm imagining it is we can
train
you could almost think about training z1
uh with
you know just cut off everything to the
right of z1
and we would train the left half of this
model
with either the the unsupervised method
with
just expression features or we could
predict this perturbed expression
and so in this case
the primary goal here is to reduce
expression or ohmic features down into a
really compressed
latent variable which i think would be a
decent argument that you could say
is a representative of cell state and
a naive approach would be to train this
first freeze all the parameters and then
train
z2 second
i probably i probably won't do it that
way but um i think that that would be
very interpretable as
or or at least more interpretable as z1
being cell state
that's how you have that you have to
after you after training is done
and you have to check if the z1 actually
corresponds to cell state
and you cannot dictate say i want a cell
state representation in z1
when you are training because it may not
be
right um so the interpretability of z1
um would be a to some extent a separate
question
however if we can predict perturbed
expression
uh which i think we we could maybe argue
is
uh is cell state to some extent
then i think z1 we would also know that
z1 has that cell state information and
so that's
that's my thought process okay
thanks for the question though sure
um
there is a question in the chat
okay uh so suppose this
resulted in enough drug candidate
recommendations that if adopted
you could observe the candidates travel
through the pipeline would there be a
way in the near future to use the data
from their journey to the pipeline to
improve your model
that's a that's a good question um
yeah that's a that's a really
interesting approach that i haven't
considered
because uh it's kind of that down the
line step
i think we could evaluate algorithm
performance to some extent
if the prioritized candidates have much
better if a higher percentage of them
make it through fda trials then that
would be
a pretty excellent evidence that our
algorithm is performing well
i'd have to think more about how we
could use that to actually
hone or constrain the algorithm itself
um yeah that's it that's a very
interesting idea
i i guess maybe i can ask the question
that sort of gets back to where i
thought
shannon was going um you know thinking
of this from a
um you know standpoint of of improving
the availability you know of drugs
um what what metrics
are you using to know that you've
succeeded is it like more drugs that
make
it into bench testing or more drugs that
make it beyond bench testing in the
clinical trials and so forth
is there any kind of metric that you're
thinking about there
um
yeah another good question
so i think if we identify um
select so targeted if we identify these
targeted therapies that are selectively
cytotoxic to
um to certain cancer cells based on
um maybe certain mutational patterns or
or expression patterns then
one that goes into fda trials and or
could go in fda trials and that's
advantageous but we can also
use this model to try to understand
patients who will be more sensitive and
therefore select patients for these
trials as well
and so we can
these targeted therapies are specific to
a subset of patients
potentially however they will be
i think that they would be more
effective for this subset
and so i think we can really boost um
that the treatment outcomes in this way
yeah i think that's probably ultimately
where you'd want to go there's there's
another there's a question by aaron in
the chat
box which i don't know how well you can
see you you can
share your screen if that'd be easy
so incorporate so what are what are your
thoughts about incorporating new drugs
into your algorithm what kind of
and how much data how much bench lab
data would you need
um for there to be enough features to
generalize to new drugs
this is an excellent question and is
probably one of the main limitations of
my model
because the way i'm encoding drugs i
have to know
the protein target and the binding
affinity
and for this there's actually limited
data so um rory's aurora blitz has done
some amazing work
in curating um both binding affinity and
drug target data for oncology drugs but
this is still pretty limited um so for
instance i
i've done some eda in uh
this drug data set called gdsc and
there's really only comprehensive
drug target data for for 10 kinase
inhibitors there
out of several hundred drugs and so we
actually have a fairly narrow subset of
drugs that we can use at this point
but um i do think that there's some ways
to address this
one there's a lot of work being done to
characterize the binding infinities and
the protein targets of
oncology drugs and so maybe in a few
years this will be much
better and we can keep adding to it the
alternative route is there's also been a
ton of work done
in creating computational models to
predict
drug targets and binding affinity and so
one idea i've been playing with
to address this this limitation is that
we could actually chain um
we could we would basically first
predict protein targets and binding
affinity for a given drug
and then we could use that in our model
and
it makes me a little nervous because
we're kind of like chaining the
uncertainties from that computational
model into the uncertainties with this
computational model
however it would really open the door to
um to the number of drugs
we could we could use at this point
that said the
since we're using this
this graph based protein protein network
to constrain feature interaction i think
that this actually
will generalize much much better to new
drugs with
with smaller data subsets and so i think
that's actually a really
that's an advantage of a framework like
this
i'm not sure okay why don't we go yeah
sorry
no no i can stop there
well i was just going to say maybe we
can take one more question from the
public there's a question
in the chat box about uh from meena
about assumption of normal distribution
of the latent variables
how good that's the assumption yeah
that's another great question
um so this gets into a little bit of the
argument between variational
autoencoders
and gains or there are some other
frameworks called so there's something
called an adversarial variational
autoencoder
which lets you assume a more complex
distribution
in that latent space
or something called normalizing flows
but the idea is that
can you make the assumption of a more
complex function
in the latent space and that's been seen
to improve
performance in a lot of different tasks
however
it requires more data and
it can affect the interpretability in
some ways
and so for for at least these this first
iteration of their development iteration
i want to start
with uh with the normal assumption
which i think is is fairly uh
you know fairly valid great okay
well um thank you for uh an interesting
talk which
generated a lot of um questions and so
um we will all leave now except for your
committee and yourself and then they
they may have further
questions or advice for you so
thanks a lot everyone and see you all
next time
thank you